The rich are growing their wealth very
rapidly and it's acting like a black
hole in society. It's sucking the wealth
away from the middle class, from the
working class, from the government. And
I saw immediately that that wouldn't
stop. I saw because just just explain
how that happens. Wh why does the wealth
go to the you know the simplest way is
you know Richy Sunnak suddenly magically
appeared in the in the Times richest
people top 100 richest people in the
country um wealth of 700 million. I
think what people often don't realize is
is the passive income that comes with
that. So if Rishi Sunak is worth £700
million, what's his passive income and
when I say passive income, I mean that
the income he gets just from his wealth,
not from his work. You know, he's going
to make around 5%. 35 million a year.
Let's be conservative. 26 million, half
a million a week. So imagine you wish
and you're making half a million passive
income a week. How much you going to
spend?
Not a lot of it. You spend, you know, 50
grand a week, live like live like the
queen. Basically, I could have spent 50
grand a week if I tried, right? So, the
the problem is once you have this group
of society with very large passive
income unless you have a rapidly growing
economy, they basically have nothing
they can do with that income other than
buy up the rest of the assets. It's as
simple as that. It's basically compound
interest. If you have the wealth of the
rich growing at 5% in an economy that's
growing at 1 or 2%, there's there's
nothing they can do. They they outgrow
the economy and they squeeze everyone
else out. And what ordinary people see
is house prices going up, stock prices
going up, my kids can't afford the
house. And what that is is the rich
squeezing the middle class out. It's the
kids of the rich outbidding your kids
for things like